So you all know self driving cars are the coolest thing ever built.
They're going to change society, make driving safer, and retransform our cities.
This course, you can now learn all the basics,
what it takes to program a self driving car.
In fact, you program it yourself.
So right now in Google's self driving car, the car that our team have been
building up over the last couple of years, I'm going to hit the button [SOUND].
>> Auto driving.
>> And the car is driving itself.
The steering wheel moves by itself, the gas, the brake.
It's sheer magic.
In seven weeks in this class, you will learn how to do this.
You will reprogram the basic algorithms and
data structures necessary to build self-driving cars.
But this isn't just a self-driving car course.
It's really a basic artificial intelligence class.
You learn about perception,
control, planning, all the ingredients that make robots really smart these days.
Prerequisites?
Well I hope you are able to program in Python.
And some good knowledge of linear algebra and
probability will be extremely helpful.
I see you in class.